in the first episode of the blood-borne
guide we found this young girl hiding in
her home alone playing with a small
music box for comfort hmm I don't know
your voice lets her know that smell
and you hunt her she's really looking
for my mom she never came back from the
hunt and she went to find him
but now she's going to I'm all alone and
scared
really oh thank you my mom wears a red
jeweled brooch it's so big and beautiful
you won't miss it
oh I mustn't forget if you find my mum
you've had this music box it plays and
of Daddy's favorite songs every one
daddy forgets us we placed the home
saying he remembers not just this city
and in love without it
look how this music box please and me
you can do it if you play the music box
while fighting Gascoigne he forgets the
hunt and remembers instead the wife he
murdered and the little girl he left
behind though if you play it for him too
many times it speeds up his
transformation into a beast as he
abandons everything the fight against
Gascoigne is a frantic even fight
between two hunters and you have to
master the art of trading hits managing
of stamina timing your dodges and
shooting him at the perfect moment I
recommend everyone defeat him this way
it's an incredible experience and you'll
feel like a god when you finally defeat
him that said there is an easy way to
defeat Gascoigne and maybe that's why
you're here now so I'll tell you as soon
as you enter the boss room run to the
right and get behind this group of
gravestones you want to stay locked on
to Gascoigne and always keep him on the
opposite side of the stones now equip
the longest range weapon you have and
simply strike away at him on the
opposite side of the gravestones other
sets of gravestones will work but I do
like this one because you're always only
one dodge away from being opposite him
the best weapon for this is definitely
the threaded cane second best is the
hunter's
and you might be able to manage it with
the saw clever now if you watched the
last episode of the guide I showed you
how to get the saw hunters badge which
lets you purchase all three starter
weapons from the messengers having the
threaded cane makes this strategy a
complete cakewalk because you can easily
keep Gascoigne on the opposite side and
it's quite difficult for him to hit you
at this range you can't do this for the
entire fight Poe Gascoigne has three
phases each triggered at a different
third of his life in his first the
hunter's axe is shortened in the second
the axe is extended and in his last he
fully transforms into a beast and
becomes incredibly aggressive each stage
is progressively harder than the last
and the last stage is the hardest of all
especially if you're trying to choose
him in his third form he destroys those
gravestones you love so much but not
trees or statues he doesn't destroy
those if you're desperate to defeat him
head over to the back of the arena and
keep him trapped in between this tree
and this statue it's very easy to get
him stuck here and even if he does get
around it just mash that role button and
get to the other side so now let's talk
about defeating him with a little bit
less cheese you should still use the
gravestones to your advantage just maybe
not as much as before just make sure
you're always behind a few when you go
to heal they stopped his spray of
bullets and also you've got to make use
of how aggressive he is it makes him
very predictable charge up those are
twos when he's walking towards you also
bear in mind that he almost always
shoots his gun as soon as he does a dash
while he's in his first phase some of
the most fun you can have is avoiding
his short axe and trying to be even more
offensive than he is he's fairly easy to
stagger so it's easy to get your health
back and his axe doesn't do that much
damage in this state and since it's
quite short it is quite easy to avoid
you can spend some bullets on reposts
here if you have more than you know what
to do with but I would recommend saving
them for the next phases because you're
going to want to get through those very
fast in his second phase the axe is
extended and obviously he has a lot more
reach staying near him will result in a
lot of his horizontal swings which make
it difficult for you to dodge to his
side's
you should be backpedaling here trying
to stay outside
axes range I rely on a lot of gunshot
reposts to get me through this phase
since his second phase attacks are a
little bit easier to predict than his
first ones if you are going to melee him
try and get in at least two attacks
because sometimes it takes two to
stagger him
you can't stun lock him so get those two
attacks in and dash back so this differs
a little bit to the first phase because
before you were staying quite in close
contact with him but in the second phase
you're not going to want to do that
you'll have trouble trading with him
because if he gets the advantage it's
much easier for him to keep you in range
so attack him when he's vulnerable his
spin attack for example leaves him
vulnerable for a moment so does his
lunge just attack whenever you see an
opening
when Gascoigne transforms into the third
phase the fight can go badly very
quickly it's no longer as easy to regain
that health his beast form has way more
poise so he won't let you recover health
easily the most common death here is
simply from being combo'd because he's
constantly attempting to get in your
space and it's quite easy to get trapped
in a bunch of gravestones the two best
ways to kill him in this phase are with
the music box or with the gun it's
always start off with the music box
you'll notice I told you not to use the
music box until the third phase this way
you save your stun for when he's at the
most dangerous and you don't force his
Beast form early the first music box
stun blasts a ridiculously long time but
you only get one stun
so make use of it get behind him and
fully charge gnar to attack for a
backstab if you don't have the music box
though your best friend here is your gun
you want to lock onto him and constantly
be backpedaling because what you're
looking for are repulsed opportunities
his attacks seem quite complex but the
most common attack is the one with an
initial wind-up followed by a flurry
like you see here it's best to try and
hit him on that first wind up like this
and if you're out of bullets
you might find it easier to switch to
Molotov cocktails if you find yourself
caught in a flurry or stamped to the
ground mash that circle button and don't
dodge backwards because if he has you in
melee range chances are he can keep you
in it if you're already getting here
dodged the side but if you are on the
ground don't think you're immune you're
not like you were in the souls games
mash that circle button and you'll
actually dodge a lot easier than you'd
think you could if this was a Souls game
if you're new to this channel welcome
this channel is devoted to souls games
and currently we have blood-borne on the
horizon for a while so feel free to
subscribe and join our community if you
have something to add to this video then
let me know what are your strategies for
defeating Gascoigne in the description
there's a link to the extra life page
for this boss fight so you can add your
own information and help out the
community jeez guys the next few videos
are going to be very interesting I think
you